but first of all french guyana next to
this of course guyana
suriname the most important country in
that part of the world
i want to go to south america and i want
to go to these three countries
and go deeper into the issue of what
about the muslims in islam in that part
of the world
because that's the part of the world in
the americas that has the majority
[Music]
muslims
[Music]
me
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm gonna start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah
key point gets closer and closer by
voluntary acts of good so like sudden
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah uh prescribes for you
which is foreign so praying fasting hajj
zakat and and
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
uh sunnah fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dona the three muslims podcast and
we are joined with
dr steph carys looking fresh today
well we have had our iftar already
looking probably as spread as i can look
after the whole day masha'allah
you what are you brothers
everybody going through with ramadan we
are joined with
you for episode three of the history
series long awaited
what are we talking about today well
today something very special i would
like to introduce my two projects coming
up inshallah after ramadan
um which um i would like to ask your
viewers as well
maybe if there's a possibility to get
some funds in because i will explain why
the researchers i'm doing at the moment
is extremely important it hasn't really
been done by muslims and by muslim
researchers
and i will introduce the projects
inshallah and let you know what it is
about
as well as there is a very interesting
workshop
coming up in jala very soon on the 29th
of may
which is a saturday inshallah 29th of
may and
it's going to be most probably around 10
ish 10 11 in the morning am
a u.s time meaning toronto new york time
um which is going to be a day seminar
and this day seminar is going to talk
about actually our identity in the west
and what we mean with the west is
obviously western societies such as
north america
australia the uk europe so how do we
muslims
fit into these kind of societies what is
our identity what is our role what is
supposed to be actually what are we
supposed to play
uh or what what what is our role
supposed to be in these type of
societies
and uh the most important thing next to
this one is actually our history in this
type of societies as many people believe
we don't belong here we don't belong to
europe we don't belong to north america
with something totally new
islam is a new comer it's a it's a
foreign body
it came from arabia it has nothing to do
in these countries
which we're going to totally debunk is
absolutely not true
and i think it's going to be extremely
important for anybody from north america
to australia
to participate to be part of these
workshops and we're not going to take
more than 10 people so it's going to be
really limited
um limited space in order to have also
this personal feeling
um to be able to give during that date
during this day seminar
to allow people to ask questions and to
personalize the issue because as i said
it is very important
it's very personal um and
i think inshallah the 29th of may should
be in your calendar should be
you should write it down inshallah so um
it's a saturday
again it's a day seminar which will give
you an idea of
islam in the west in north america in
australia in europe how did we get here
how did islam get get here and why is it
here
and why does it have a right to be here
and what is our role
and what is our identity in these kind
of countries so we could actually take
this as well to discuss today inshallah
this is a topic we should discuss today
i think as well
and lead into that workshop uh but next
to this one i would like to introduce
or introduce us the two projects that
are coming up inshallah very soon
after ramalan and i'm collecting some
funds
uh i'm on gofundme the page go fund me i
think we all know that
and on gofundme you can find basically
these two projects but i explain more
details but i would like to go into them
one is in south america and the other
one in the balkans
um so yeah it's below so if you have any
questions before i start inshallah just
let me know we could do it that way that
i could introduce the first project come
back to some questions with regards to
the americas islam in south america and
america and then
introduce our second project which is in
the balkans in in europe and then
go again into these type of topics is
this all right
let's do that let's get it started any
questions before i start anything you
want to ask anything you want to mention
maybe
now um as you can see on the slideshow
hopefully you can all see the slideshow
islam in the guyanas okay now first of
all questions to you three
okay because we don't have another
audience at the moment um
the guyanas where is that caribbean
oh yeah so yo
yeah yes and no
a bit more specific
uh you got me i don't know actually it's
not far away from puerto rico
espanol they don't speak spanish there
by the way it's a very important point
you know growing up growing up i had a i
had a neighbor
and it was like this family they were
guyanese and they were muslim
okay right you know and when when we
figured out you know
they don't look like us mom but they're
muslim how is that how's that possible
and she's like oh what do you mean you
don't need to be you know brown or odd
up to the muslim
yeah that's that that that is you you
hit it right on that's exactly what it
is
and that's one of the reasons why i want
to actually start this project and go
myself to south america i've been there
before
and as i told you i think my wife is
from one of these three countries
okay and there are three i actually
spoil the beans a bit but
there are three of them they used to be
called guyanas the one was british
guyana
the other one was dutch guyana and the
other one was
french guyana which still exists the
french guyana is still french guyana
and take a look at south america you see
brazil obviously massively big country
above brazil in the north of brazil you
see three tiny countries
the smallest actually on the south
american continent
you see guyana which used to be called
british guyana
okay the blue part next to this one in
the middle
suriname which used to be dash guyana
and all the way to the right french
guyana which is still french guyana
belonging still to
uh to france as an overseas department
okay so do you see them so all the these
are the smallest parts the smallest
countries actually in south america
but they might be small and tiny and
seemingly insignificant
but what is very important about these
countries is that there is a massive
amount of muslims there
and the official number is not at all
the real number i mean
officially i can tell you know i mean
hopefully now it gives
gives you a little bit of perspective
and you were right before when you said
fire
caribbean yes it is they all have a
coast caribbean coast indeed
but they're also part of south america
okay which makes them
being like you know in between of both
and they do
they have a very tropical feeling indeed
i mean when you are there you feel that
you are somewhere
close to the caribbean now the first one
is a map an
old map an old dutch map because
guyana and suriname used to be part of
dutch guyana of
the dutch empire and the dutch empire as
small as they might be you might not
think that the dutch once had an
empire but um they did
rule the largest muslim minority
majority country in the world which is
be awake guys come on i'm asking
questions a bit oh
the largest muslim majority country in
the world is which one
indonesia man i was muted mashallah
that's it
i got you guys i got you tonight
that's it indonesia indeed indonesia
more than 250 billion people
muslims all of them all the majority of
muslims masha'allah
disappeared what happened to you did you
fall over
did you know that i had to turn
the uh the fan off my eyes are getting
really dry right now i'm
dehydrated so you got you got this now
so indonesia is the largest muslim
majority country in the world
and it used to be a colony of the of the
dutch i mean you wouldn't say it's like
i don't know how many times bigger than
holland the netherlands
but massive country um
with most islands in the world by the
way isil island nation and that you see
that they also used to
have colonies in south america and one
of them was surinam
and until the day of today so dutch
guyana as it was called
until the day of today it's the only
country outside of europe
where they still speak dutch as an
official language okay
so you wouldn't say but in south america
there's a dutch-speaking country
where the education is in dutch where
the whole system is in dutch
where you will find dutch boards on the
street you know and people speaking
dutch
but first of all french guyana very
short because it's the smallest country
actually
it belongs to france yes indeed it's the
department overseas department of france
with the capital cayenne more than 300
or about 300
000 people so not a massive massive
population
however for an overseas department quite
a lot
um a muslim population who mainly
are arabs or lebanese and afghans
and you might say like how did they end
up there i mean what about the afghans i
mean
what do they do there now don't forget
the endangered labors coming from from
from
southeast asia from india and
surrounding
afghanistan is far away but still
surrounding the indian subcontinent
basically
so there are people from that area who
came as well but because we don't have
so much information that's exactly
the reason why i want to undertake this
kind of project
i want to go to south america and i want
to go to these three countries
and go deeper into the issue of what
about the muslims in islam in that part
of the world
why in that part of the world because
that's the part of the world in the
americas that has the majority muslims
actually
okay now the greater toronto area gta
okay has in north america the biggest uh
population of muslims for north america
but for the americas as a whole
these three regions especially sharing
them and
guyana they do have a massive amount of
muslims up to 20
people say the official figures are
lower but the inofficial ones say
up to 20 okay massive yes it is
i mean imagine where we are in the
caribbean right um
now islamic center and a muslim school
in cayenne and in kuru cayenne is the
capital
kuru is where the uh guyana space center
is you must have heard of it
it's run by the french
but it's a european space agency
basically the europeans have their space
agency there they
send rockets to the moon and that is in
kuru and that's why they keep this
this this colony basically you can say
this department still right that's why
it is still in the apartment but it's
very poor
okay and i'm not talking about the
europeans who live and work there
talking about
the indigenous population the people who
live there who are extremely poor
so that's all we know about french
guyana with regards to islam that's
about it you know there's some lebanese
and there's some afghans there that's
about it we don't know a lot
so that's exactly why i want to go there
that's why i want to find out more
next to this of course guyana guyana as
brother fayette said before already he
had some
uh experience with brothers with people
from guyana
who um you said didn't look like you so
how did they look where they're black
where they they looked
mixed they looked they looked like a mix
between african and
uh maybe like latino yeah
so indians right because indeed the
majority look at that 40
of the people living in guyana are
indians of indian origin
40 of the indian subcontinent 30
are of african origin 20 are mixed
but again it's not very clear you know
but again 20
mix the official statistics 10
indigenous amerindians
1 others meaning chinese portuguese
english people and whatever else
okay so a massive massively interesting
mix and when you say they
they look mixed that is the majority of
people actually even the ones who
identify themselves being like rather
africans
or other indians even they are mixed
actually you know there is the
population is totally mixed
and the crazy thing about that is the
population is not bigger than 750
000 that is like um um
like one of the hoods in in toronto i
mean 750 thousand yeah
what is that you know you know
so basically it's not even uh it's not
even a
[Music]
a city in america you know it's like
it's insignificant
that's the whole population of a country
imagine that but look how mixed they are
and look at their history um it used to
be a dutch guyana
between 1667 and 1814
okay and then it became british guyana
between
1814 and 1966 so the independence
they gave it in 1966. so imagine
uh for for quite a while right 1667 to
1814 it was dutch
and they did re some of these things
from the dutch remain for example
the main market which i'll show you now
the main market
you see that it's called star brook
do you see how they write star broke
market it's star
b r o e k o e in dutch is ooh
you see o e makes an usa okay that's the
phoneme so brook which is dutch so star
brook market
okay so it is a typical market in
georgetown in the capital
and you see our ladies there masha'allah
the ladies who are
out on the market going shopping right
muslim ladies are there you see a masjid
of course also there
many mosques are there mashallah
georgetown and guyana
as a very big amount of muslims martial
allah
and the official statistics say let me
see officially they say
63 christians 25
hindus and 7 muslims
okay in officially they say up to 14 to
15
muslims okay so it's double the amount
most probably
okay because don't forget this massive
conversion rate
okay and it's very interesting honestly
very very interesting to see
um suriname the most important country
in that part of the world
in suriname we have the most muslims
with a smaller population even the
population is is not bigger than half a
million 550
000 imagine that it used to be dutch
guyana
dutch is the only the official language
is the only country outside of europe
where they speak dutch as an official
language um
independent since 1975
the capital is paramaribo
um 27 indians so less than in george in
in guyana um 22
africans but 16 official again creole
mulatto what does it mean
nothing else but a mixed population
people who have grown up there and
mixed with the others and again other
mixed 13
so 16 plus 13 makes it more than 30
mixed people and this is the official
statistic so inofficially as i mentioned
before
in um in guyana there is
the most of the population is mixed
already then something that is very
unique
next to the dutch language is something
that's extremely unique in suriname
there are javanese muslims javanese from
java from indonesia
why because you can imagine why it was a
dutch colony
the dutch took of course people over
from java and you remember what i said
last time
how did islam enter south africa
they put uh they put scholars there
right just to hide them away
they got scholars from indonesia they
touched on indonesia
and they have sent them to uh to south
africa right
thinking that they would die there
basically alone somewhere in a hut
in the desert that did not happen in the
country so
um now here in that case we see javanese
people people from indonesia
who are the only bigger population with
the gas to muslims
in that part of the world next to that
one there are amerindians of course
indigenous people
one and a half percent chinese it's not
nothing it's quite interesting
one percent europeans and two percent
others whatever
there might be still under others i
don't know what what else can they fall
under there
but it's unbelievable you find anything
in suriname it's really incredibly
interesting
and if you just take a walk through
paramaribo you really feel that you are
um that everybody is present you know
any kind of of color
any kind of creed and i find it exciting
personally
i i find it very exciting and i love
that the country
um so yes i think it's an eye-opener for
all of us now
to find out a bit more about especially
if you are living in north america to
find out something more about south
america
you know and especially with regards to
islam there and islam is thriving
i must say again it was not that case
before
like 20 30 years ago they did have halal
butchers and all this stuff
but just from the formality nowadays you
even have hijabs and women with hijab
that time i remember my wife was one of
the only ones in paramatic
hijab okay when we were there nowadays
mashaallah what i hear i haven't been
there for a long time
what i hear is that sisters have come
out now with hijabs and everything
so it is a common um um common
thing on the street you will find uh
women with hijabs on
on in on paramarico streets um
this very interesting again two pictures
the bigger one
is indian laborers who came over in the
19th century
um and the smaller one are the javanese
i was talking about indonesian muslims
okay masha'allah now 550 000 inhabitants
not more
what was for a small period of time 17
years a british colony the british
colony of willow
willow beland and then from 1667
until its independence 1975 it was a
dutch colony
with about 50 christians 22
hindus 14 muslims again the inofficial
figure says about 20
even muslims and then two percent who
belong to
the winter cult which is an african type
of
um religion and three percent others
okay so just to give you a very general
idea again
any questions with regards to these
three countries up to here
anything you would like to mention maybe
did you expect that did you know about
that
i did not no i'm not i'm gonna be right
back i gotta get some eye drops got my
eyes are killing me
bro i remember watching a tick tock by
uh
rami and he was saying that uh when you
basically normalize
not wearing the hijab you basically
alienate
wearing the hijab right along amongst
with anything in life
so when you were saying that you know
back then a lot of people weren't
wearing the hijab that's why
you know more women didn't want to come
out of the gym but then when they
started normalizing it
then it was it was it was just there and
now you can expect that if you go your
wife wouldn't be the only person wearing
a job
absolutely you're absolutely absolutely
right it is um
indeed there has to be the beginning has
to be made by somebody who's courageous
let's put it that way
somebody who just decides to okay i'm
gonna wait although listen i mean the
crazy thing is what about suriname in
suriname you'll find islamic schools
you will find mosques you will find
madrasas you will find one mosque next
to the other look at this money for
example
look at this one this mosque you can
clearly tell which one is the most
there's a mosque in a synagogue
up there in the center of paramaribo
you have a masjid with a very typical
indian style
right because that shows you also that
the majority of muslims
are either indonesian or indian or
so you can see that the architecture and
next to this one there's a synagogue
a jewish synagogue so that i find in
itself again
is amazing okay it shows you that
again it is not a privilege of of of
european christians being in south
america or having established colonies
or whatever
it is it is something that is clearly
it has invited i mean the americans have
invited many people from all over the
world as you all know
so it's not something that is a
privilege for specific people
being white or being christian no you
see clearly
that in this country for example in
suriname you clearly see there's a
jewish minority there's a muslim
minority
there is a ahmadiyya minority for
example there's many
many type of different different types
of people hindus as we saw
more than 20 hindus we you don't find it
anywhere else in the americas
25 indiana 22 in serena
massive amounts right massive amounts so
they do play a role
okay um a typical um
yeah street in in in suriname and
paramount as you can see here or in
suriname at least um and it gives you an
idea that dash language is present
this is dutch by the way whatever you
see here it says
it says it in dutch the suriname dollar
is the official currency
um yeah and these are
real pictures from our brothers and
sisters celebrating eat in serena
[Music]
mashallah several years ago indeed very
exciting and very interesting i mean
look at
the children wearing hijabs you know as
i said before it was
it was uh the the the men look how they
addressed mashallah i absolutely love it
and the most important thing is what
that the eat celebration the eat day
is celebrated by the entire country it
is part
of the the culture of the country
as well as suriname so the president of
suriname is present during the
prayer you know that the president of
guyana by the way several years ago was
a muslim
okay guyana and suriname are the only
countries in the americas
that belong to the organization of
islamic countries
i remember my parents my parents had to
fight tooth and nail to get eid off
as like a legit religious holiday back
in the day like i know
i know today they kind of come up with
it and only chris
uh christmas isn't the only one so they
allow it for eve but i remember back
then
they had to really you know let them
know that it's actually a religious
holiday
but nowadays it's it's a common thing
isn't it i think it's very yeah it's
very common now
yes yes but imagine it has become this
is not a new phenomenon
it was always like this i mean surinam
guyana they have accepted the eat
celebration always for the whole country
so it is something that they all
celebrate
on the other hand you can come and say
of course for that reason they expect
the muslims also to celebrate christmas
and easter because
you know if we do that for you then you
do that for us right that's the idea
that's a little bit tricky now okay this
is a little bit tricky now this issue
shall we now that's the point here of
integration assimilation which i
mentioned very often in the
in the lectures and workshops which is i
think
one very important topic what does
integration mean what does
assimilation mean what is the difference
and what
are we allowed to do as muslims and what
are we not supposed to do as muslims
this is extremely important because you
can now see basically what we see in
suriname what we saw in suriname
10 15 20 years ago was a part of
assimilation of rather sick
you know a nice type of assimilation
because you can be muslim no problem
in the same time you can celebrate us on
christmas right with us you sit at the
same table
you know with your half christian family
the other one half muslims whatever
everything is fine and nice let's all
done satsang and lambada together no
problem
but that's not the way it should go okay
now we misunderstand the idea of
integration you know
that doesn't of course again the the the
danger is again
if we do fulfill integration and we do
get away from assimilation we
get into the third problem the isolation
problem
so suddenly we become an isolationist
religion
isolationist people who live in their
ghettos
far away from the majority population
wanting their own halal mead
wanting their own schools their own
infrastructure that is not exactly how
it should be islamically
i hope i hope it makes sense what i'm
saying so that
we have really a problem that we have to
tackle as muslims
and again this is something we will
discuss deeply on the 29th of may
inshallah with regards to the workshop
that we're going to offer inshallah
which is going to be something um
talking exactly about
these issues like integration
assimilation how do we as muslims
integrate in a western society
non-muslim society
as in north america europe and in
australia
how are we supposed to be part of a
society but still
keep up our islamic values okay
um it's not a one-way street guys i keep
saying it is not a one-way street
it is us and it is them as well
a muslim has to of course in order to be
integrated
has to accept the fact that they are
living in a country which is surrounded
by non-muslims
they are surrounded by neighbors for
non-muslims they have contact with
non-muslims
absolutely no problem with that but now
you have to keep up your values
you should not lie you should try to be
a good man a good
good man good woman a good good citizen
of the country
you have to of course also adhere to the
rules and regulations of the country
you cannot just go against it because
whatever you cannot just do that
but again if the country starts becoming
a little bit more difficult for you
because of you wanting to wake up
such as in the case of france right you
take france as an example
as an extreme example of fascism
right a country of fascism which clearly
tells you
we don't want you to wage up this goes
against islamic values
there you cannot say i want to integrate
so i'm going to take it off
okay this goes against your values this
is part of my value this you cannot come
and tell me
i cannot do that the same like you
cannot forbid me to pray if i have to
pray
okay the time that i take off as an
employee
and i go to smoke every two hours by the
way you are allowed to smoke
so i don't even eat every two hours to
go to pray imagine that
but a smoker can go every two hours and
have a fact
i don't do that i don't need that i need
to go and pray
but this once once maybe a day or twice
but somebody was small smokes every two
hours right
this is the regulation so why doesn't
this count for me i mean i'm not doing
anything against anybody else i
i'm going to so this is a discussion
we've been having in europe for example
the whole time
why don't you understand that
integration is not a one-way street it
goes both ways
both have to accept each other and both
have to tolerate each other
otherwise you can say well most probably
the sentiment is rather an islamophobic
sentiment
sentiment so don't hide behind your
fingers don't say that no no we are not
we are not we accept you we have no
problem with islam we have a problem
with radicalism what are you talking
about
is somebody ready to praise five times a
day let's call the muslim in my books
okay right so you know i mean you cannot
be like
you cannot play around with words as
they do yeah you remember you remember
when you said uh
like you need to be stronger courageous
like go pray and
not assimilate but integrate the same
thing you were saying how they had to be
courageous sisters to like wear the
hijab
right in like a non-muslim country i've
seen so many articles saying
more and more strong courageous women
are taking their jobs off
oh yes they're courageous right i'm just
so courageous
yes yes because that's in the end that's
where it's going to
they want to they will not reach you
with a majority but that's exactly the
test that we have to go through
it's a test i remember when i was living
in holland um
that prayer was an issue i could not
i could not perform my prayer and i'm
talking about an eight hours job
when i did not demand a two again the
two hours of smoking because i'm not
smoking
but what i wanted i didn't even want my
room nothing i just wanted in the time
of my break
five to ten minutes i wanted to go make
my wudu go in the corner somewhere and
make masala
i did not disturb anyone but they had a
problem with it
there was an issue they did not fit in
the work ethic
they were saying something like that
whatever this might mean you understand
so there is really a question of wait a
second you don't
you you're simply islamophobic that's it
there's limpy islam you have a problem
there's simply an issue with of me being
muslim it's not an issue of me demanding
something
i'm demanding something is my right
actually that is my right but
i'm not demanding something which could
have been my right if i had said i want
every two hours of my break to smoke
i would have got it you know it would
have been normal
that's the craziness about it but anyway
it is interesting to see
how do our brothers and sisters down
there in south america where they've
been an established community now
um how do they deal with these issues
alhamdulillah
it is like this that there are islamic
schools down there and i mean you all in
the americas that's something i
appreciate very much and i admire
in the americas in general there there
is never an issue about an islamic
school i mean this is something standard
from canada all the way down to
argentina
you have you can find islamic schools
you will find islamic communities
being able to have their own
infrastructure their own halal shops and
all the stuff this is in europe
nowadays again in certain countries
where it was normal before
it has become an issue nowadays in
france they're closing down halal
butcheries why
they've been existing for the last 30 40
50 60 years
some they're closing down the halal
butchers now what's going on
why why can't you slaughter anymore
what is happening why do you have a
problem you know because you do make
your salah you pray
during the during your working hours or
school in germany
somebody was sent i remember i was a
young boy 14 15 16 year old boy
he was sent to court because he was
found he was found praying somewhere in
the corner so he was this
not disturbing anyone imagine that guys
he was not disturbing anyone he was
somewhere in a corner in the break
he was performing his salah and he was
sent to court
in switzerland a brother comes in meets
another brother in the bus
he says the bus reports this
and he gets a fine of a thousand dollars
so now you explain to me please but this
is that this is not that
something is everything is going well no
something is going wrong there something
is happening something is going on
so that's why these kind of projects are
extremely important i want i personally
want to learn from these people about
how is it working in south america how
come
that you're living in the west that
you're living in certain
societies where the majority are
non-muslims how can you be integrated
and not only integrated actually
financially they are the better off
people
you know that in suriname and in guyana
for example you will find many muslims
um being actually entrepreneurs and
rich and wealthy business people right
and this is not possible in certain
parts of the world where you cannot even
just because of your beard
you have already an issue yeah and i'm
not joking i'm really not joking it is
it has gone into extremes
you know so yes eaton suriname
celebrated by the whole country
the president himself is present
masha'allah and it is
beautiful to see all these people
gathering together they're non-muslims
they're sitting in the back they have
their seats and they're participating
whereas the muslims are making the salah
you have the imam there masha'allah it's
beautiful to see and everybody is
stressed everybody's happy
everybody eats together celebrates
together alhamdulillah this is a nice
thing that's the way it should be
you know there is no threat and there is
no no
bad feeling and ill feelings now our
sisters in the sun
now as you know almost probably
especially uh angel
in in maya or in in um
in florida obviously you know that the
umbrellas there
are used against the sun and not against
the rain contrast to here
we use the umbrellas for the rain guys
okay down there marshall our sisters use
them against the sun
to protect themselves from the sun
marshall right in puerto rico the same
right
they also use umbrellas i guess ah they
just
they stand out they're like this they
get the sun
so our sisters in suriname again it
gives you a nice idea
beautiful absolutely beautiful we're
coming back to that
so up to there with regards to the first
project the project of islam
in south america and especially in the
guyanas
three three countries in the region
where it's absolutely unknown to us we
don't know really what's happening down
there we know nothing actually we know
very little about them
and i would like to really go myself and
get some
get some research done speak to some
muslims down there get some interviews
done
and get them to tell us actually in the
west tell us in europe like how can it
be better than what we have here in
europe for example
and and why is it better why is it
better why are there certain issues no
issues
and why are there certain issues issues
here and why are there no issues there
so that i find extremely exciting and to
also you know
find out about the different ethnicities
you know the javanese people
i know that they still speak their
language and they do raise their
children in islam
and they're quite strong martial in
suriname which is very nice to see i
remember when i was
in a certain area in paramaribo where a
lot of indonesian japanese people live
i remember i we went in into a garang
into um
into an indonesian food shop
to buy some food and while
um we ordered i remember next to us
there was a masjid and we heard the
other
and you were like wow masha'allah i mean
this is surinam
and you can hear the adhan you can hear
the people calling the muslims calling
for prayer mashallah this is amazing so
we left the show went for salah and came
back to pick up our food
i mean mashallah this is beautiful you
know and i'm sure that you can
you can understand what i'm talking
about where i'm coming from i mean this
is something that we would wish to have
here
and i i find this nice that there's an
opportunity to to experience that
mashallah and
it is there it is there um i don't know
how this is situation actually
you both are in toronto how is it in
toronto i've heard good things about gta
very good things i know that they're
containing pertaining to what oh muslims
yeah freedom for muslims i mean
you know mosques i mean you do have
mosques i know you do
you there's a lot of activities but
no don and all that it's nothing like
like new york city or something like
that
nothing like that in what way does it
mean there's there is a van in new york
city oh there's
yes there's there's muslim literally
neighborhoods and
you'll have more like uh neighborhoods
that are more culturally
like for example you have bengali
neighborhoods pakistani neighborhoods
not really muslim neighborhoods
so in those neighborhoods you'll find
more you know
traditional restaurants halal food
readily available but it's not really
muslim it's more like culture
but in new york city for example you'll
find actual like
muslim areas because african americans
that's what african americans exactly
exactly
i was in the states i was in new york
actually in philadelphia in 1991 guys i
mean
i know this is like i know like um
that was that was my first and last time
i was in the states um
and i did a tour actually from new york
philadelphia new jersey all the way down
to miami to florida miami
the keys and it was amazing absolutely
amazing and i did visit some muslims
that time that time i was at the very
beginning of my islam
and i visited i was excited about islam
and i knew about malcolm x that's all i
knew
and i visited some african-american
brothers in their shows marshall and
they were excited about me
visiting them coming from europe
mashallah so that was nice that was in
the 1990s
uh but what you're telling me now about
new york this is sorry
you ever been to calgary uh calgary no
in canada it's a city in alberta there
they have a
good muslim population really yes
lots of you know muslim you know halal
stories everywhere butchers
uh mosques as well i mean toronto is
known for that
not really there's masjid for sure
there's much
there's a lot of masjids but i don't i
don't particularly get that bad
i don't know romney you can correct me
if i'm wrong
um it really depends like with me um i
find a lot goes on like before covert a
lot was going on with like i3 and ira
and different
organizations we have like our irs and
our ras pardon me
um and all this stuff once a year i
think there is a good muslim community
to be honest we have
no problem with halal food and all that
stuff so i think alhamdulillah are
pretty good
we don't have like they don't um call
the event out loud for everyone to hear
it's only like ever in the masjid
so to hear you have to be in the masjid
but in terms of of all that i think
we're good
at msas in your universities and
colleges and all that i think we're um
we're pretty good alhamdulillah
other than the societal diseases we deal
with as a whole as an entire society
as muslims alhamdulillah i think um
we're doing pretty good we can
definitely do better obviously but we
can definitely do better
the the things um not to go against you
bro but the things that you're listing
are things that should be the standard
anyway and i find that in common place
almost everywhere
there's nothing in my opinion
exceptional about toronto
for islam yeah because what i've read
sorry brothers what i've read is really
i mean i a lot of praise for the muslims
in gta
i mean having having a lot of okay as
you said massage it okay we have them
everywhere also here
there's not a problem uh having
hilarious shops having everything
basically pretty much everything there
that you need um
and having also the emotional i mean
feeling safe and feeling as a muslim
welcome let's put it that way is this
the case
yeah um yeah definitely um but the city
that me and
rami live in mississauga it's part of
the gta it's not part of toronto
that city there's more of a muslim but
for sure you know heath comes along
people are praying you know they're
doing it salah in the grass you know
in schools people are going it's about
for sure pre covered yeah
toronto not really the same that's it
interesting interesting um how's it down
there man
i mean oh it's beautiful really
tell me i'm just stressing right now
no no no i mean next i didn't mean down
there there i'm talking about you down
there in florida
[Laughter]
in florida is it's nice it's um
[Music]
i don't know much about like the muslim
population
i didn't think there was much where i
stay at because i stayed in claremont
which is a
kind of like a country slash suburban
area
a lot of white folk nothing against the
white folk but there's a lot of white
folk
and um i i went to uh
the vitamin shop the other day uh the
muslimah was coming out of the story oh
they asked
went into target the other day i saw
like two muslims i was like oh
subhanallah
i guess there are muslims here there are
other muslims
you see the problem with ramadan many of
them are i know
many more coming on yeah yeah
no i mean look you cannot i think the
situation in north america in general
if you compare it to the rest of the
world i really think it's quite good
of course yeah like some of the things
that romney was saying
i agree like compared to places like
france for sure bro
euro are doing we are doing so much
better europe is really bad
i mean the best country is why we are in
the uk's for that reason
i moved to the uk in 2000 2001
simply because i knew i i saw what was
happening in
in the netherlands in germany in
switzerland in france in italy
you know there was no way you really if
you wanted to stay in europe you could
you had to move to the uk that time
london birmingham manchester
you know these are places where you feel
okay and welcome as a muslim but
the rest of europe i mean honestly it
has become so bad
that when i go back to where i grew up
in germany i grew up in a
in a town 250 000 inhabitants when i go
back there people look at me and say
like what is he doing there
you know although we do have muslims
there we do have a lot of muslims
actually there
but the majority muslims are these what
you mentioned before
the traditional type of muslims you know
and because they are bangladeshis they
are muslims
because they are pakistanis they are
muslim because they are turks they are
muslims
that's not why you are muslim and i
always catch people in the in the
lectures when they look at me like when
i ask them
why are you muslim they're like huh what
do you mean
i said why are you muslim and nobody has
ever asked me that
of course because you have asked
yourself you have to understand that
even if you're born muslim you're
you you're born into a muslim family you
have to understand that once you have to
make up your mind and decide are you
muslim or aren't you muslim
and what it means to be a muslim is very
simple following the five pillars of
islam
you know you're not muslim because
you're bangladesh and you're not muslim
because you're pakistani you're not
muslim because you are whatever
turkish or indonesia or whatever you're
a muslim because you follow these five
pillars of islam
right that's why you're a muslim and you
should be muslim because you fear your
lord you fear allah and you want to
reach paradise that should be
reasons for you to say that's why i'm a
muslim not because my father comes from
pakistan
that's not the reason brothers that's
not the reason and every time i have it
in lectures you know
i really seem to catch them off guard
when you ask born muslims
why are you muslim it's like uh
you know uh i chi well you know
oh my father is from pakistan well it's
nice that your father's on bikes my
father's from greece
so i shouldn't be muslim right you see
so they don't see that it's
automatically really like
no yeah because you're from there you
have to be there
you told me you told me this thing last
time last episode if um some guy was
saying i was born
greeks i'm a dying greek that's right
what they mean with that is you can just
be greek
christian when you agree you know you
cannot be anything else
subhanallah so subhanallah with regards
to south america with regards to
islam in the guyanas obviously that is
one project which i find extremely
important and i would love to go down
back again
when i was there last time it was really
just to visit family to visit people
who um also guyana has to visit people
who um are close to my family or i even
family
as i said my wife is from serena so um
what uh the second project is about the
second project is about europe
and especially the balkan peninsula um
what do you know about the balkans all
of you
nothing any idea nothing
anything recent that happened in the
balkans honestly like
i like greek yogurt and when i go to the
grocery store and i buy some greek
yogurt
i get the one that says balkan style i
don't know what that means but it tastes
really good i think it has something to
do with it
yeah i mean indeed greece is part of the
balkan
okay the welcome peninsula is quite a
big peninsula actually and i'll show it
to you later
but there are many definitions i mean
the general definition
is the following if you look at these
countries on your right basically on the
slide you can see the slides all right
mm-hmm
tell me now you just see wallpaper or
something
all right so the balkan peninsula you
see these countries on your right
these are countries with the dates in
there when the ottomans came and opened
them
mashallah so when the ottomans came into
the 15th century
most actually in the 14th century
already 1360 for example
they opened the north of greece okay in
greece as you mentioned before the greek
yogurt indeed greece
is part all the way to the south um is
is part of the balkan peninsula the
balkan peninsula
is now has a lot of countries before it
used to be basically
just two or three or four countries one
massively big yugoslavia
you must have heard of yugoslavia the
yugoslavia war in 1992 to 1995 the
balkan war
you must have heard of it right between
1992-1995
bosnia right hello
i mean it brings it rings a bill it
sounds wrinkly
but i i can't say that i can recall like
my
you see if i told you now if i told you
what is the holocaust
oh i'm gonna tell you that yeah i can
tell you that you see you can tell me
about what happened 70 to 75 years ago
but you cannot tell me what happened 20
30 years ago just in front of my house
though
that's crazy but that's that's because
of the schooling that we have exactly in
the west
that's the point i'm trying to make and
i'm reaching it look at that
what happened who were the victims in
the balkan wars in in yugoslavia at that
time the breakup he was live in 1992 to
1995
what happened the victims were the
muslims okay
and they used to call muslims turks told
them to go back to turkey
but they were slavic people that means
they were the same people who are living
there on the balkan peninsula
all the time speak in another language
by turkish speaking a slavic language
okay and these people bosniaks for
example
are muslims commands are muslims
albanians are muslims
right and they were the victims of these
wars algeria yeah nobody talks about
what france is algeria
no absolutely not and this is recently
this is recent history guys
this is recent history i experienced it
we were you know we were viewed in front
of the tv when it was happening that
time 1992 1995.
okay it happened and i experienced it
not there of course i was not there but
i experienced it
you know i saw i saw the the
documentaries and i saw people
while it was happening refugees who even
went to america
i know her brother told me once i had to
love subhanallah
um he told me he was in new jersey new
york
um when he told me in the 1990s
when they accepted some refugees from
bosnia muslim refugees
and they opened the mosques for them and
they allowed them in
and he came in to speak to them and he
saw white people then he was like where
are the muslims
and they told him listen these are the
muslims it's like these are white people
you understand so people have this idea
in certain
everybody in certain parts of the world
there's a certain idea of muslims
okay in the uk they're all pakistanis
okay in the u.s they're all black right
in greece they're all turks okay in
france they're all moroccans or
algerians you understand and
in the end this is the whole world so
everybody has their muslims
and they believe that just these people
are muslims
okay so so you see again the
the prejudices that are there even from
the muslim side so again the brother
could not believe that in my the first
time in my life i saw a white muslimah
somebody was wearing a hijab a white
lady was wearing hijab it was the first
time in my life
you know crazy isn't it i found this
crazy when i heard it i still have to
laugh when i think of it
you know so people don't know about the
balkans and the balkans nowadays have
three or four muslim countries imagine
that one of them is bosnia bosnia
government is a muslim country albania
is a muslim country
kosovo is a muslim country and turkey is
a muslim country subhanallah
so you look at these countries
you know and i would like to go to the
balkans again
and um do some more research make a
small documentary about actually
what has happened after the um
the destruction of yugoslavia
that got basically six other countries
seven countries
developed out of yugoslavia out of them
three muslim countries
the albanians for example live in kosovo
and in albania
you know how do they cope with their new
situation now it used to be a communist
part of the world they used to be
suppressed and they could not really go
to the masjid
now the masjids are open they can go
they can practice their deen they can go
back
and albanian people for example look at
them here
albanian people live all over the balkan
peninsula
they're about 5 million people this is
the original uniforms that you can see
here
and this is an old picture of albania's
praying during the time of the ottoman
empire
they became muslim during the time of
the ottomans so it is exciting to see
that these people are still there
nowadays
still being muslims and they have
islamic architecture
like for example here this is in albania
okay so you can find mosques like the
minaret you see here the typical
ottoman style minaret in the center of
tirana of the capital of
albania and inside of this mosque it
looks like what you see here
behind um you know the balcony that you
can see as a background the photo
mashallah
beautiful to see okay the typical
ottoman architecture you find the houses
you can see down the two pictures on in
the corner
um it gives you an indication of old um
villages and towns which still have the
ottoman architecture
okay and people still go to the masjids
and masjids are available and then is
there of course
very interesting to see and i would like
to actually visit these places and
and bring of course some some some
footage from there
to to show to the people like how people
live nowadays in the balkans
after the breakup of yugoslavia after
communism has disappeared basically
the same the slavic people as i
mentioned before look at that now you
can see
the balkan penis like more clearly you
see
countries such as croatia bosnia
sagovina serbia montenegro albania north
macedonia greece
these are all part of the balkan
peninsula bulgaria
and they were all opened in the 14th
century by the create by the ottomans
up to the 15th century actually and
islam became a major religion actually
there
so that many of them are muslim
countries nowadays some are not but they
have a muslim minority
okay like greece we have a muslim
minority in all places
the slavic population in the world is uh
significant and nearly 200 million
people
uh of whom the russians are the majority
of us more than 150 million russians are
slavic of slavic origin and then you
have ukrainians and other
slavic people as well as polish people
czech people these are also slavic
people
and then the balkan people are 23
million sloths slavic people
so if you look at them in the bosnia or
in serbia
or in bulgaria or in north macedonia
these are slavic people
okay and many of them have accepted
islam
some not are orthodox people or other
type of religions
bosnia herzegovina of course as we all
know after the
breakup of yugoslavia the bosnian war
in the 1990s you can still see until
nowadays look at the first picture all
the way on top
this is the capital of
bosnia-herzegovina sarajevo
and in sarajevo until the day after day
after 30 years of war
even until the day of today you will
find
uh residential buildings such as these
ones here
where there is you can still see the
bullets the bullet holes and you can
still see what happened in the war
until the day of today subhanallah
these are muslim people and they really
were
the victims of the war especially in the
1990s
okay with beautiful mosques from the
ottoman time that are renovated
and made what have the ottomans left
behind the ottoman muslims and islamic
legacy in the balkans
you can find ottoman islamic
architecture as we saw
before islamic populations of course
muslim countries
ottoman turkish persian or arabic
vocabulary
you can find ottoman literature and arts
until the day of today
a fusion of ottoman and albanian as well
as ottoman
and slavic cultures and last but not
least the millet system any idea what
this is
the millet system the ottomans and
islamically seen
that is a system that in an islamic
country
in an islamic empire you
would deal with your subjects according
to their
denominations that means if you deal
with
orthodox christians they belong to the
millet of the orthodox
if you deal with catholics they belong
to the millet of the catholics
jews belong to the millard of the jews
muslims the millet of the muslims so
that means
it's like religious communities in a
muslim country
ethnicities don't count it doesn't
matter if you are
from that country this country black
blood yellow green
well what counts is your who do
who do you worship okay what god do you
believe in
and this is your military belong so even
if you speak different languages
like the orthodox people on the balkan
peninsula there are
serps who speak serbian there are
bulgarians who speak bulgarian they are
greeks who speak greek
but they all wear one millet they all
belong to the orthodox people author of
christians
clear any questions up to that so these
are the two programs i wanted to
introduce and whoever
can help me out go to my gofundme page
and take a look at this project in
details
find out what you can basically
do for us and help me out to go and
visit these countries and come back with
some nice footage
show it to you on youtube basically get
you to find out how these muslims live
nowadays
and this is something that's all long
overdue already we had to do that
already in the 90s
beginning of the 21st century hasn't
been done and if it has been done it has
been done by non-muslims
always from a certain perspective never
from the muslim world
so insha'allah whoever wants to support
these two projects
this is i think it goes into the sadaka
issue so
description rami how much more time we
got
it's literally six oh 36 yeah all right
yeah we're almost done wrapping it up
anyway yeah subhanallah
this is i learned so much man i really
every episode with you it's like
i forget that we're recording for
youtube i feel like i'm in lecture but
it's not like a normal class like i
actually want to go
yeah i want to say i hope it was not
like a lecture i really hope that
you know we take something with us
because look i mean we spoke today about
two
very different places but what they have
in common is you have the muslim
muslim life in both ways and you have
the muslims developing
that in in these regions of the world
and with different history and different
background but exciting to see as a
muslim
that i could feel at home i know that
i've been in
i've traveled a lot mashallah and i've
been to
many muslim communities in the world and
even if i was in the deepest jungle of
south america you know brazil or
whatever
and there were muslims there subhanallah
i mean in suriname you have even
indigenous people living
in their villages who have become
muslims so whole muslim villages
so it feels like home it doesn't really
matter if i'm in greece if
i'm in the uk in the u.s or in uh
in suriname for me as long as we have
the freedom to practice our deen
and we have the brothers and sisters
around us i really could live
anywhere in the world anywhere in the
world as long as there's freedom
and i think the place i could not live i
tell you that now already would be
france
that would probably if you want to
really um do something
to me if you want to give me a trauma
sent me to france
you know that's some that's that's a
place i would never like to go
you know i visited france several times
in the past but
now it's the time i would i would not
even want to give them any money
so it is these are places you know where
you clearly see that there's a problem
and the problems are developing
throughout europe it's not only in
france unfortunately
yes i hope indeed i hope it was not a
lecture it was rather some kind of
presentation to learn something more
inshallah and to
find out more about these projects and
actually see
this is part of my work i've been busy
with that actually for months already
trying to prepare for it and trying to
get um
get a funds for it as well um
yeah inshallah i mean again if you could
just promote it a bit inshaallah it
would be absolutely great
i will put it in the description as well
see how we can take it further
[Music]
it's a great initiative great
presentation and backed by great
initiative
i'm excited for a personally subhanallah
i think it is very interesting
uh and it's it's something that like you
said has not been done and i think
that's a big issue
and it speaks to a larger issue um that
we're not
really pushing for things like this to
be done we're not really
educating each other on you know other
muslim
populations around the world how they
got there what they're living like there
what life is like and uh
i really do support it and may allah
bless you make it easy for you oh yeah
exactly
in session
exactly indeed indeed it's something
that i'm hoping
that will wake up a lot of people as
well
um to look into um
how different people how better in
certain parts of the world
muslims live and how much better they
are treated as well
and i think it gives you hope
um on the one hand on the other hand
also you see that is possible it is
possible to integrate and not to
assimilate
and not to have to assimilate uh see the
two these two different terms
and understand these two different terms
and try to really push forward that we
want integration
not assimilation as it is in certain
parts of the world
um that it's possible you know that is
not a one-way street it is something
that
both have to agree upon both sides have
to agree upon
and it should not feel like us and them
it should never feel that way
although it might seem like that it
might really seem because i said it even
before but
it might seem like this sometimes um but
it doesn't have to be like this it's
really not us
um it is simply that everybody wants to
have also dignity and respect
for their way of being and if you
do give respect to people who want to be
i don't know who just simply feel proud
of being white
or american or black or whatever else
then give us also the respect that we
want to be muslims and we want to
be accepted as muslims and never as an
ethnic
minority or a re or a linguistic
minority but rather a religious minority
which we take it more seriously we take
really again
as we are all here four different people
from four different countries
from four different backgrounds but what
really unites us
is the belief in allah and this is
excitingly amazing
honestly it's amazing you know this in
itself is mind-blowing
imagine now i you know when i met you
guys you remember when we met the very
very first time
you know when we met the very first time
for me i met brothers
i didn't meet somebody from god knows
where i didn't care
it's interesting to find out okay it's
interesting to know that you have these
different backgrounds mashallah
great and i want to know that as well as
the languages for example
and hope uncle we're going to speak
spanish instead of next time so
inshallah
so it is it is it is exciting to see
that you know it is really
wonderful to see how we unite mashallah
and that's how the ummah should be we
are microcosm of the woman
what we are doing here four of us is is
is playing the microcosm of the um
so that that's it
yes without notes hashtag integrate not
assimilate if you really made it this
far so we know who the real
t3m fam is look forward to episode four
which will drop soon and yeah
with that being said for another amazing
session yes
without you this wouldn't be possible
thank you for your tremendous work may
allah
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm going to start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith question where he says
that the most beloved acts of worship to
god are those which he made obligatory
the person continues to get closer and
closer to allah key point gets closer
and closer by
voluntary acts of good so like certain
uh um things you know for the sake of
allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
uh sunnah fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]